welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how the
government tracks your every move and
knows where you are at any given moment
that's right michael we know that you're
watching big question right now on your
phone we're on to you michael we're on
to you
you see right through the screen
my name is mt i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt so glad to be back
on on the big question here in the blue
dungeon having a great day watching
every move everyone's making out there
this screen works two ways my friend yes
we can see everything you're doing clean
yourself up you drop some cheetos on
your shirt mary
sorry i looked up a list of all the
popular names just to free people
well done but anyway what's our big
question for today brandon well mt the
mcu has grown so much over the years and
has so many heroes spread throughout the
galaxy it's been a while since we've
seen a lot of these people uh you know
they haven't got any movies lately and
with a new big mcu film just around the
corner it leads us to this week's big
question where are all of the major
players right now in the mcu that's a
great question brandon and the answer is
contraxia getting laid
by all those beautiful yellow robots
side big cube we haven't even started
side bq do those robots do they have
choice like are those robots allowed to
choose to be sex robots that's a good
question how is their ai work i don't
know
yeah because it's like we know in the
mcu that like robotic consciousness is
like kind of just real people at this
point in in the mcu so like do they have
a choice to i hope so i hope that
they're just making their money i hope
they do and you you folks at home i
don't care what you use your computer
for but don't just use it for one thing
okay give it some other stuff to do
give it some nice things to look up on
the internet don't just turn your
computer into a machine for your
pleasure okay let it look at some other
programs let it do some other things
every now and then okay
be kind to it jeez seriously i think
your your meat deserves a break yeah boy
bring me off a key piece of that kitkat
bar instead and not oh my god
that is a great question my friend
because as we get ready for love and
thunder the next major film in the mcu
timeline we thought it'd be a good idea
to check in with all the heroes and
remaining avengers to see where they are
at and what their condition is so we're
about to go all project insight on all
these superhumans and track them down
just watch them but in a good way we're
not going to shoot anybody like if you
uh that's no good
we're not gonna nobody no one's getting
shot from the sky
by nick fury by accident
no don't don't pay no attention to that
giant flying helicarrier yeah it's
totally fine it's for everyone's safety
just kidding it's hydra just kidding but
it's time for a roll call in the mcu so
let's begin with the original lineup of
the avengers and starting with
everyone's favorite big green machine of
anger bruce banner aka the hulk the last
time we saw smart hulk he was back in
bruce form at the end of shanghai and
his arm was still in that sling showing
the damage from the performing the slap
the slap that's a we're moving out from
the slab oh wow showing the damage from
performing the snap and end game to
bring everyone back and shangxi takes
place in 2024 before the events of
spider-man no way home now we've seen
smart hulk in the trailer for the
upcoming she-hulk series and there
appears to be no damage to his arm
anymore which is kind of weird so maybe
that means the series takes place after
chongqi and bruce has found a way to
heal but either way right now bruce and
the hulk should be on earth possibly in
a tropical location yeah it seems like
hulk's hanging out in the islands
like i think at first we thought oh
maybe she hooked took its place like
during the snap or like at a weird time
before shanxi but the fact that there's
no sling action
uh in she-hulk makes me think it's gotta
be after right it it's gotta take place
after shangxi so wang an abomination in
chongqi
that happens before she-hulk somehow
that's what i'm thinking right right
that makes sense i mean like it could be
possible i think it's very likely that
like she-hulk could take place during
the blip period because like i feel like
that's the only way to explain why he
looks fit and like he's like all right
i'm like completely okay but like i i
could know also but even hulk had a
sling and end game so why would he why
would banner need a sling
if bruce doesn't need a sling or or hulk
doesn't need a sling anymore it's got to
be fixed right i don't know it's so
confusing it's a weird thing but like it
could you could be 100 right and like
this is after shang qi and he just found
a way to just like
him and hulk just figured out he is the
hulk after all and like he can heal
right fairly quickly so it's possible
but maybe however they were going to
heal that damage he had to be a banner
to do it couldn't be a hulk right he
goes down to banner he gets all fixed up
and he's like you know what i kind of
like being smart hulk it's a little more
fun for me as a guy so i'm going to go
back tomorrow when are we going to get
hanging out
man
like i really want to see joe fix it
hulk grey hulk like the one that works
in vegas like he's just i just love that
all cuz it's so stupid
gotta do it but yeah uh we also have
four in the guardians of the galaxy of
course because thor is currently flying
around space with the guardians of the
galaxy crew making money and saving the
universe together one planet at a time
minus a time displaced gamora so that
covers peter quill rocket groot drax
mantis and nebula we have no idea where
gamora is and might not even see her
again until guardians of the galaxy vol
3 which would make sense yeah i doubt
they'll touch on it and they'll probably
have some line of like oh they'll show
peter looking at a computer screen with
a map yes looking despondent and then
just be like we don't we haven't found
gamora yet into the end of the story
we'll check in you later on volume three
peter's gonna dress up as wolverine lay
down in his bed and have a picture of
gamora and just be like oh i hope so i
hope so so bad
quills just now getting the the x-men uh
cartoon to watch so he's like just
catching up on that meme we also have
hawkeye because following the events of
the hawkeye series set in late 2024
hawkeye is hanging out on the family
farm on iowa and just training kate
bishop and though his hearing has been
greatly affected by years of doing
avengers flash ronin work he's shown
that he still got the hawkeye juice to
do all the sorts of murdering and stuff
he could still he's still a player he
could still do it i think he wants to
retire i think he's done being a
superhero but
if if needed if called upon he could
come out and help do some fighting okay
for sure like all he needs to do is
stretch he learned from civil war you
just gotta stretch a little bit if
you're gonna we're gonna do some
avengers oh you gotta stretch
i knew it should have stretched and of
course we got steve rogers aka of the
old captain americans because we don't
know where old mancap is right now it's
the big mystery in the mcu yeah some
people think he's on the moon um which i
think might actually be possible i hope
he's on the moon because i feel like
there's a lot of i don't know why he's
there but he could be there
well i feel like there's a lot of moon
action in the mcu right now because we
have the moon as a factor of moon night
of course i mean that'd be kind of
concerning if it wasn't and we have seen
the moon in in uh the thor love and
thunder trailer like for some reason
needs the moon so like i think that we
could actually see be seeing captain
america on the moon just being like
hey uh white vision what are you doing
here dude
why did you just smile into space
but we don't really know where this old
man cap really is like is he dead who
really knows so eventually they're going
to have to answer this question but i
don't know if thor love and thunder will
be that place specifically yeah we know
that like the the public doesn't know
what's up with with captain america
right there's the funny joke about that
yeah he's on the moon that's what i
heard but like they've got to have some
sort of story i hope mc marvel producers
kevin feige he must know the answer and
he's just waiting to reflect oh maybe
they just don't know what to do i don't
know maybe they're waiting to see if
chris evans will put on the old man
makeup and come back i don't know i
would really love if chris evans
actually did show up and throw 11
thunder it like because like this this
is a story about someone being worthy of
taking up the mantle of thor the last
person that was steve rodgers or young
man steve rogers rather and so like it
would be really i would love a
conversation between old man steve
rogers and jane foster just be like
being where they just means that you you
just you just do good things and have a
good heart or something like that and go
go do your thing girl um something like
that just be nice i don't know because
they're both human
the only two human worthy people on the
planet
it would also be a good person for thor
to talk to right because thor kind of
wants to lay it all up and retire and
you know
steve had to make that choice and he did
make that choice because he got to be
back with his lady and caused the
bravest timeline and maybe destroy the
universe who knows uh but you know he
would be a good mentor uh for thor when
he's looking at like what what does the
next phase of my thousand years of life
look like no for sure like it just i
feel like thor looks up to steve rogers
a lot which is kind of ironic because
he's a god but like he finds steve
rogers to be like the most the best of
human humanity and so like it would make
a lot of sense for him to be like you
know what my my good friend steve rogers
had a nice he got to hang it up and
like enjoy his love and i am tired of
all this thunder so let me focus on love
instead there you go
i don't know
we have to talk about natasha romanoff
and tony stark because uh uh they're no
longer with us um if they died being
heroes as they are so unless we get a
very tony from another timeline or
someone who figures out how to get
natasha's soul back we probably won't be
seeing them again anytime soon they're
probably gone
i think they're gone for good for now
yeah for now until secret wars we're
gonna see i i guarantee i have a feeling
i don't want to guarantee but like rdj
got to be coming back rdj please come
back for civil war it's gonna be amazing
uh but yes that's the original avengers
team but let's check in on a few more
people um that were added on to the
roster like people like vision our
beloved vision has been killed
reanimated and killed again about one
two three four fifty times now but we do
know
so many times but we do know that there
is a white vision flying around out
there somewhere searching for his
purpose could white vision decide that
gore shouldn't be killing gods and does
white vision even believe in gods what
god does white vision believe in um
computer god man zola i mean
the visions the visions you know they're
they're logic minded beings both yeah
our og vision and white vision but
there's plenty of evidence that these
gods are real so they they must
acknowledge that fact i mean they see
them probably as aliens or
interdimensional being beings not gods
uh not capital g gods right but uh yeah
white vision i wonder where he is like
what he's up to he's got to be somewhere
he's not just flying around in the sky
like he's gotta be landed somewhere
somewhere secret though where people
aren't around i straight up feel like
this is gonna be such a weird theory but
like i honestly feel like white vision
is on the moon you love you're just
putting everyone on the moon straight up
like i think that white vision because
he's a sword um he has the sword matrix
in his brain and sword has satellites
and space i think he went to the
ultimate satellite in space the moon to
have a think just be like you know what
i don't really know what i'm doing
because i feel like i should love
humanity but like i have all this evil
in me i don't know i'm just gonna think
about it i mean it puts that it puts
that famous poem whities on the moon in
like a whole new context
we're talking about white vision it's a
whole new context i can't pay no doctor
bills but white is on the moon
10 years from now i'll be paying still
while white is on the moon
like he straight up be doing his like dr
manhattan thing i'm tired of these
people
and their problems i exist beyond time i
mean in theory white vision can do the
the scarlet vision trick right of like
making himself look like a human so he
could just be wandering around the
streets just being a weirdo coffee shops
being like what do you think is the best
coffee for a human to do
there's also doctor strange of course
because like as for this good doctor
following the events of multiverse of
madness he appears to be off worlds now
helping clea deal with her dark
dimension incursion now i don't think
that he'll be showing to help out thor
at all in this movie yeah now he's gone
for now if we're gonna talk about doctor
strange we gotta talk about the man
himself the president of magic sorcerer
supreme long back and commentary and
he's just recovering from the damage
done by the scarlet witch because she
really messed up commentary completely
so he'll probably show up for at least a
scene in thor love and thunder because
you can't really have an mcu film now
without an appearance from wong because
he's the new colson he's he's if please
don't die like coulson please do not
kill off wong if anyone i don't i don't
care if the entire universe dies and
wong is at the end of the universe he
needs to be he who remains because he is
the man long the king himself yeah we'll
definitely get a long appearance in thor
love and thunder he appears in every mcu
property he obviously runs commerce does
he like run
uh
the new york sanctum too i mean i guess
doctor strange runs the new york sanctum
but he just walked through a portal with
clea i i hope he told somebody before he
left
that's so true he'd be like hey wong i
need you to cover for me for maybe a
thousand years who knows how long i'll
be gone for but also we got to talk
about our friendly neighborhood
spider-man currently swinging around new
york city and following in the events of
no way home he's still all on his own
which is very sad and nobody knows that
peter parker is spider-man now so in
theory nobody knows how to ask him for
help so unless any of the activities
from thor cross over into new york city
we probably won't be seeing him anytime
soon though it would be funny if the
only person
that the spell didn't effect was thor
but thor had no idea
in theory he never met peter parker
maybe he met him at the funeral like at
tony stark's funeral because he'd
probably be like who the hell are you
why is this teenage boy it's pizza the
boy the problems and the the puberty you
know you know
he's got the web coming out of his butt
or something like hey peter does that
mean that mary jane's up for grabs now
oh my oh yeah he's he's way older than
any woman he's ever been with yeah if he
dates anyone on thor he's robbing the
cradle let's be honest anyway ant-man
and the wasp and they're most likely in
san francisco working with hank and
janet on quantum technology and
exploration of the quantum realm because
both scott and hope would want to be
close to their families so it makes
sense for them to be on the west coast
yeah i think they're definitely hanging
out in san francisco though uh scotland
is my is my like wild card pick for a
cameo and thor love and thunder so i
think walking around i could see him
with his with his with his daughter and
his ex-wife and bobby cannavale walking
around new asgard just on vacation like
taking pictures and stuff when all that
when all that stuff goes down and maybe
he gets in the fight a little bit but i
think that's that's my like wild card
cameo is like scott lang's just on
vacation in new asgard i would really
love that to go on vacation with the
families like he wants to go see a play
in a new asgard let's do it i have cool
friends now and he tries to like meet
thor and thor's like i have no idea who
you are and he's like hey man i was a
little guy we were doing the fighting
thing
we met at tony stark's funeral i don't
know
i just feel like kevin feige is most in
my opinion is setting up a west coast
avengers type of scenario um because i
don't think that we're gonna i mean we
might see the young invaders but i feel
like we're just gonna have like the west
coast avengers be established first
because i believe chongqi who is next on
this list is also based on the west
coast as well that's right and i'm sure
that he's still out there hanging out
with katie staying trained up and
shredded and uh you know just doing
push-ups in his garage being
an unfairly handsome man good god simu
um i'm jealous of you and your entire
existence it is weird that wong didn't
ask him to come help fight the scarlet
witch that would have been badass to see
the scarlet witch go up against chung
chi but knowing how powerful she is that
was probably for the best because if she
got a hold of those yeah that'd be some
real some real problems yeah i think
that yeah sean she's definitely not
ready to to fight the scarlet witch um
because like we saw her popping into
people's minds and he had to tell
everybody to fortify your mind which is
one of my favorite quotes in fcu history
because the delivery was spectacular i
loved that i i always say it to myself
all the time when i get distracted i'm
like empty for to file mind it's also
funny to think that you know they were
examining those rings and wong's like oh
it's like calling out to something we
have no idea what it's calling out to uh
here why don't you keep these zhang ji
take these out of my library right now
please thank you so much yeah go hang
out in san francisco that's fine it's
like you have a phone number i'm sure
whatever it's reaching out to is super
nice and will come and give you a hug
that's fine
we'll be sure to bury your corpse when
it comes
we'll give you a lovely funeral oh you
should have been there for tony stark's
funeral it was great we got to talk
about of course nick fury and maria hill
because both nick fury and maria hill
had squirrels replacing them on earth
during the events of spider-man far from
home in the summer of 2024 and we got
confirmation that fury was on a sword
space station during this time it's fair
to assume that maria hill was up there
as well because they are two peas in a
pod they work so well together um
they're homies for life so we probably
won't be seeing any of them again until
the secret invasion series but if gore
poses enough of a threat to earth we
could see them again sooner yeah i agree
[Music]
yes
yeah i mean i don't you know i want nick
fear to come back but it does feel like
they're really waiting on secret
invasion for that yeah it would be good
to have a nice check in on in thor 11
thunder because we haven't seen him in a
while but i think they're just waiting
course not here to destroy earth he just
wants to kill some gods and i'm sure
nick fury's probably like yeah go ahead
mum should take off one of these guys
don't trust him anyways nick fury knows
that we can handle ourselves he's like
all right he's like yeah i take out a
few of them that's fine we also have sam
wilson aka the new captain america
following the events of falcon and
winter soldier he's probably still
working with the us government to keep
america safe as captain americas are
prone to do possibly overseeing whatever
the grc is up to these days after his
impassioned speech telling people to
just get along because why not um it may
be still getting some help from bucky
barnes aka the winter soldier aka the
white wolf aka uh the most handsome man
in the world the most from
the most handsome man from uh the 1940s
that is still alive at the um
it's bucky barnes he's now at peace with
his past transgressions and fully passed
all the hydra programming and he could
be helping sam wilson with his business
in um cap four um we also know he likes
to hang around captain america in
general so he could also be visiting
some old friends in wakanda the falcon
winter soldier series was a lot about
him you know getting over everything and
just putting it behind him getting out
there trying to date again but
he's not going to hang it up forever
like he still wants to be working i
don't think he can like officially work
for the us government there's still like
that weirdness around like the fact that
he assassinated a bunch of people i
don't know
they probably gave him a full pardon but
they don't really trust him but i'm sure
he's still helping sam with whatever's
going on and especially if yeah if sam's
going back to wakanda for any reason i'm
sure bucky's like i would love to tag
along please thank you so much sam's
really his only friend like it's he's i
mean we saw in falcon soldier that he's
very anti-social and he doesn't really
like talking to people so um it just
makes sense that like we saw him just
adapt himself to this new family and so
like yeah he just hanging out with his
new bestie i think wakanda was like
don't come around here for a while
because uh you're too hot right now um i
mean not physically just uh you're too
hot in terms of you've done some bad
things we gotta talk about black panther
and sherry and okoye because we also
have to talk about all these heroes
currently in wakanda and this that
includes shuri okoye and even the black
panther and i'm sure they're not going
to address the t'challa situation until
the black panther sequel wakanda forever
but for now it's safe to assume that he
is in wakanda along with shuri and okoye
yeah i mean we did see bass right is
going to be in thor love and thunder so
there could be some what kind of
connection there but i doubt they want
to they don't want to get into any of
like the people living in wakanda
because everyone wants to know
how they're going to address t'challa so
i'm sure they're just going to skip
right over that and just deal with bass
uh and not deal with any of the
uh
uh humans down in wakanda right now yeah
for sure because like i definitely feel
like this is like ryan coogler's
territory to handle right with the story
of like what happens to t'challa like
after you know the terrible tragedy of
his death um
so yeah i don't see them like maybe they
might hint as to like like maybe like a
new avatar for bass binding chosen but i
thought like i definitely don't think
that um we'll see any yeah i'm sure they
don't want to get into it in this movie
i mean there's a possibility that shuri
is in oakland right uh
right working at that center that they
opened up but she's probably in wakanda
right now you know what that's actually
i totally forgot about that because they
did open up that um the outreach center
i'm in oakland so like i there is a good
chance that she is there considering
that it seems like the mcu is leaning
towards a more west coast um a base so
like all their stories don't take place
in new york anymore which is which makes
sense um and plus like if we're having
mutants uh magneto has to move that
golden gate bridge at least once oh
i yeah got to talk about war machine
because i always saw in falcon and
winter soldier rhodey is still working
with the us military and he probably
won't be appear again until his armor
awards series or possibly even secret
invasion because you know i would love
to see another cameo and if brody is a
skrull i will cry
i will cry
and
my god like it would be hilarious if he
was a skrull since iron man 2 and he was
supposed to look like terence howard but
he's just like i don't know
i don't know
but also let's talk about captain marvel
the boo thing of one war machine in the
comics uh and that's probably i think
they're setting that up um
and they're like oh be safe
wink wink but yeah captain marvel is
definitely flying around in space
dealing with many issues going on
throughout the galaxy there's a lot of
drama a lot of people talking [ __ ] about
other planets she's just the mediator we
saw in the post-credits scene for
chongqi that she had to dash away to
deal with something very important so we
could all assume that she was still off
planet yeah she's gone not on earth
doesn't care about gore she's not coming
back she only shows up during the big
events like in the game you know she
didn't really care about us she's like
call me when you got a real threat and
speaking of captain marvel let's talk
about monica because monica unlocked her
abilities while traveling through the
hacks in one division and she met with a
scroll at the very end of that series
who indicated that her talents would be
needed somewhere else potentially up in
space on the same sword space station
that nick fury is still hanging out on
and the events of one division happened
before the events of spider-man far from
home so monica could have already been
in space by the time we see nick fury on
that station which yeah i love this idea
i think she is already up there she's on
the space station she's maybe even like
has teamed up with captain marvel at
this point i don't know but yeah she
won't be on earth we won't see her in
thor love and thunder let's talk about
loki because our loki is dead but there
is still a variant loki dealing with the
now changed tva that exists outside of
time
somewhere out there somewhere out there
it would be great to see him check on
thor though in thor love and thunder
though i don't know if the words ready
for that yet especially after
back tattoo
yeah yeah he's seen he's seen he's
thought loki was dead so many times and
then actually watched him die at the
hands of thanos i i would love a scene
of like loki
popping in to see thor but like thor
doesn't see him and loki just wants to
make sure he's okay or something he'll
be so sweet i would cry so hard uh but i
i don't think we'll see him at thor love
of thunder but ugh i think it would be a
good spot to put him in but don't have
the meat don't have the meet-up just
have thor or just have loki check in and
move on you know he's got other stuff to
deal with i would love if loki was about
like comes through a tva door and like
he's about to go say hi to thor but then
like thor's talking to cory's like you
know if my if my brother's faking it
together i think i'll strangle him
myself
if i ever see him alive again i will
carve out his pancreas
maybe not yet
a couple thousand years bye but let's
talk about valkyrie our king valkyrie
rather i'm so sorry i'm gonna address my
royal highness as in such terms because
she's the new king of asgard with korg
and meek by her side but of course we
all know that from the trailer it's not
a really surprise but we still have to
be thorough because yeah we got to put
her on the list we know she's going to
be in the movie she's on new asgard
that's where she is she's doing her
thing but let's talk about the villains
now because like we know where our
heroes are but where are our villains
let's start off with wanda maxima
because
last time you saw her she was not doing
so great um on that mountain yeah you
don't really know if she's alive or
she's dead
right but she's not gonna be a factor
yet she's gotta
yeah work work through some stuff right
now um we also do have baron zemo who's
still a factor but he's still in custody
at the hands of the wakandan military
yeah um so he's probably in wakanda i'm
just scheming ready to do some some bad
things and he'll probably show up in
some way and and maybe wakanda forever
just maybe like a little teaser even
though anthony mackie has said that like
oh man i i don't really i'm not really
going to be in wakanda forever he does
know
a lot of details about the set and like
what's going on so i feel like
he might actually be in wakanda forever
because like this is a this is a tribute
to
chadwick boseman the first like black
panther in live action and black panther
was the first black marvel hero and so
like he paved the way for
this new black captain america so it
would be weird if he didn't show up in
my opinion but anyway yes he'll
definitely show up so yeah i can
definitely see zemo also just being like
him just checking up on zeo and being
like haha you got caught you dumb
purple bastard thanks for all your help
uh you're still in prison we also have
the abomination who was in custody at
this weird prison facility that we'll
see in she-hulk and also made an
appearance in um shanghai as well um we
don't we really haven't seen him since
the events of 2008's incredible hulk so
it's still super great to see see him in
chongqing and also here we also have
justin hammer who is still in custody at
seagate that revealed that wenmu was
still in the shadows uh being the real
mandarin as the leader of the ten rings
and sort of just retconning the whole
i'm the mandarin killian thing from iron
man 3 which is a very good choice
because we would not have shown she
without it so uh i think that we'll see
justin hammer more in
armor wars if anything more because like
i would love to see him back is he
confirmed for armor wars i don't know if
he's confirmed but i mean he's got to be
a part of it right he's got to be like
it would be very sad if he wasn't
because like he just oh my god so good
so good let's talk about ghosts because
from ant-man and the wasp she is this
reformed villain but still needs some of
that sweet quantum juice to like sustain
her unstable
atoms in her body i mean we assume she's
on the good side now but the you know
she could easily slip back into her bad
behavior who knows yeah i mean like i do
feel like we're gonna get the story of
her father told in quantum mania with
the with um her father is of course
elias starr who is the famous ant-man
villain egghead who is like ant-man's
number one enemy in the comics um so i
just i think it makes sense for her to
still be
kind of bad because her bad father is
still a factor in the mcu i don't know
that's just a weird thought for me yeah
we also have to talk about zola because
zola as we see in what if has had
multiple zola copies around there still
is always
yeah there's definitely out there alive
kicking and you know just waiting to be
booted and put on a uh a usb stick but
let's talk about val's crew that we were
introduced to in falcon winter soldier
because we also know that val has a
couple of new recruits under control
including elena bulova and us agent john
walker so we never really know when they
might show up again so it'd be cool if
uh we saw one of them appear in
411 thunder or maybe like a new addition
to what we think is of the thunderbolts
being disassembled right the mcu yeah it
would be cool to see them in like
she-hulk right that they work out of
that prison
the cube we think it is uh i'm gonna get
it somewhere that'd be interesting if
that was their home base otherwise i
assume dc is their home base i don't
know that could also be where we see
like the power broker sharon carter
again uh involved with like val and her
trickery so who knows but yeah they
probably won't be a big factor in thor
11 thunder but they're out there they're
out there waiting correct they're out
there
but that that's our mcu world call who
do you think might be the wildest
appearance in thor love and thunder my
friend you know i think scott lang
showing up not as ant-man but showing up
with scott lang would be a lot of fun uh
and be be pretty wild i definitely think
we'll see a wong you can't you can't
keep long out for too long yes uh
like wildest wildest if they find a way
to work in like
captain marvel like that would be pretty
crazy if she like flies by and it's like
i don't want to deal with gore that's
too much for me i got other stuff to do
like that would be kind of crazy
what about you what do you think would
be like a wild i think it would be
super nuts if hank pym i know you said
scott lang but like i think that like
pym tech could potentially come into
factor here because like there is a
prison in the marvel comics called the
big house that shrinks
all the bad guys into little tiny people
right and the little tiny cubes so like
so they can destroy them easier so like
i can't really think of a better way to
store the abomination than to put them
into a little little box but yeah what
do you guys think is gonna be the
wildest appearance and thor love and
thunder let us know in those comments
baby because we want to hear what you
guys think you guys are so smart we love
you we know that you guys are even smart
because you guys love picking up our
latest obsession shirts on
newrockstarsmerch.com it's like the
smartest thing that you guys do and it
really helps the channel and you should
check out our newest latest obsession
shirt empire's most wanted inspired by
the obi-wan kenobi series and when you
buy this limited edition latest
obsession shirt you unlock the
opportunity to get a shout out on our
weekly wookie lead series our obi-wan
kenobi after show hosted by eric voss
and tommy bech told so once the shirt is
sold out it's gone for good so be sure
to visit new rockstarsmerch.com to grab
your latest obsession church today and
before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that help bring big question to
you people like mint mobile because have
you ever signed a contract with tons of
fine print from a big wireless provider
to get some incredible deal only to find
out there's this super secret catch it
feels like there's always a catch these
days but what if i told you mint mobile
offers premium wireless starting at just
15 bucks a month without any cash what
if i told you that it's row reynolds
company so he does unbelievable things
all the time mint mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
out the cost of retail stores and pass
those sweet savings directly to you and
several members of the new rockstar
staff has made the switch to mint mobile
for this very reason philip loves the
convenience that mint mobile offers as
well as the fact that he got to keep his
phone number and all of his contacts
when he made that switch so for anyone
who hates their phone bill mint mobile
offers premium wireless for just 50
bucks a month and mint mobile gives you
the best rate whether you're buying for
one or for a family and that mint family
start at two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text and high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network so switch to mid mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month so to get your new
wireless plan for just 50 bucks a month
and get this plan ship right to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com bigq
that's mintmobile.com bigq cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mipmobile.com
big hue now it's time for our bite size
question brett are you ready oh a bite
size quick wait what's that oh
yeah switch things up asking for bite
size this time
oh yum all right brandon how much would
it cost to build a death star in real
life and this is from chicken chips on
twitter thank you chicken chips oh yes
thank you chicken chips we all know the
death star you've heard of it it's no
moon it's a space station baby it's
probably the most famous ultimate weapon
in cinema history the death star is a
giant mobile battle station capable of
destroying a whole planet with just one
little
laser uh but how much did it cost to
build well wikipedia uh the the better
version of wikipedia with the cost of
the death star at over one trillion
galactic credits that's a one with 12
zeros uh their source for this figure is
star wars absolutely everything you need
to know a book released in 2015. though
most of the film-related facts in the
book are considered canon some of their
facts rely on legends material which
wasn't considered canon post the disney
buyout in 2012
and this is just like a little fun
coffee table fact book if we try and
conceptualize one trillion galactic
credits it's kind of difficult because
it's just like greater than one trillion
we don't have an exact figure so it's
like oh it costs more than a trillion
collective credits to build uh great uh
but at the same time the empire was also
seizing planets and their mining
operations and they weren't exactly
paying for all the materials and labor
that went into making the death star
wookies had to build for free and get
fed meat i don't know
messed up stuff so a forbes article from
2012 tried to answer the question as to
what it would cost to build the death
star in our world uh and they turned to
some economic students from lehigh
university who calculated it would cost
852
quadrillion dollars for just the steel
necessary to build the battle station so
that's 852 with 15 zeros behind it or
roughly 13 000 times the world's gdp in
2012. so way more money than the world
even has
to build the death star what if i used
to coupon brandon how about that well
if you used a coupon
if you got 10 off that's uh
852 i don't know what's just before
quadrillion dollars uh so not not a bad
coupon but still a lot and so you're
gonna need a lot of steel too and while
the earth's crust doesn't even contain
enough iron to make the steel to build
one death star our core does in fact you
could make two billion death stars from
the earth's core uh though getting all
that iron out would be quite the
challenge uh but yeah there's a lot of
iron deep down in the earth but not so
much in the crust to build a death star
but once you have a death star uh what
are you going to do with it how are you
going to how much does it cost to even
operate this thing well the british
energy company ovo energy surmised it
would cost 7.7 octillion dollars to a
day to operate the death star so that's
a seven followed by 27 zeros uh a very
expensive piece of machinery to keep
floating around in space
i've never heard the word octillion
before in my days
so yeah not very cost effective to build
and own a death star just skip it just
be nice to people okay seriously just
forgive your enemies it's way cheaper
now our second bite size of the question
of the day is do you think that on earth
838 there is a captain carter musical
this is from fray girl on discord thank
you free girl yes thank you frey girl
this is a great question it really
really made me think okay so in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness we
saw an alternate universe where peggy
carter took the super soldier serum
instead of steve rogers this earth earth
838 also had an illuminati and mutants
and the fantastic four but none of that
matters here baby we want to know if
captain carter the captain britain to
our captain america not that captain
britain but you know what i mean uh got
her own musical does carter the musical
exist in the west end of the 838 like
rogers the musical exists on broadway in
the 616. well let's think of the notable
things that steve accomplished to get
that musical to see if peggy's antics
would line up and we'll consider that
some of what we saw in the first episode
of what if happened to 838 peggy carter
as well since that's like the best
evidence we have of how you get to a
captain carter okay steve was created to
help fight in world war ii uh he took on
the nazis and red skull he died
heroically he didn't really die from the
ice but they thought he was dead uh so
we could say all the same happened for
peggy right she was created to help
fight the nazis she fights the nazis and
the story is probably that she died even
though we saw her go through some portal
uh and that's how she got to the future
right uh so we assume all that kind of
happened for her so that would be one
indication of like oh there's your first
act of the musical baby okay uh and so
then steve fought the chitauri invasion
and we can assume that peggy did that
too because what if showed how she made
it to modern times
and we know that the 838 fought off
thanos on titan so we can assume the
early stages of his plan were like the
same right he probably tried to invade
earth
and whatever the avengers looked like
then possibly the fantastic four helped
fight the chitauri maybe some mutants
helped fight so yeah peggy was probably
involved in that battle too so that
would be there so then steve rogers like
he fights thanos to undo the snap uh and
as far as the public knows he maybe dies
during that fight so that's probably the
final act of the musical right his death
or presumed death peggy never did those
things uh in the 838 they stopped thanos
before the snap ever happened and as far
as the public knows in the 838 dr
strange is the hero there right they
built that statue for him and they're
like he died fighting thanos to save us
all right and for the public like that
might not even be that big of a thing
for all the things that happen right
that
the illuminati coming out and saying
like oh we stopped thanos he would have
ended the universe or he would have
killed half of all life in the universe
the public would just be like yeah sure
great add it to the pile of awesome
things you've done that doesn't really
stand out in our minds because we never
felt the effects of it but doctor
strange died fighting thanos and saved
us all great we'll build a statue for
him so yeah peggy does wind up dying
fighting off wanda but they might lie to
the public of the 838 about that as well
right they may not say what actually
happened there so i don't think there
was a carter musical in the 838 at the
time of multiverse of madness because
she's still alive she's still
functioning and she's just another hero
on the illuminati but maybe just maybe
they're working on it now like after she
does die maybe they're like maybe
england's like oh we got to make a
musical for our greatest hero but i do
think during the time of multiverse of
madness they had a strange musical in
that universe because he was their big
hero they had probably some weird rock
opera called strange uh and it was all
about using magic and it had cool
effects in the in the show and stuff
like that so i don't think there was a
carter musical i think there may be
working on one now but i think there was
a strange musical like there was a
rogers musical on earth 616.
i think that actually makes a lot of
sense i think the strange musical makes
a lot of sense because just because he's
the savior of the world he was the hero
that died right yeah thank you brandon
for these amazing answers you're an
amazing man with a smart brain and i
love you very much but now it is time
for our box of scraps brandon oh
baby put it in the game with a bunch of
scraps
amazing now brandon if you had to go
into hiding where would you go and what
would your secret identity be would it
be ben kenobi by any chance ben oh i
don't go by brandon i'm ben berrick now
no one will ever hear that now uh i
think if i'm gonna go into hiding
somewhere i wanna do that scenario where
you move to like a small
european town maybe like a small town
somewhere in italy and i become like a
baker uh the mysterious baker that no
one knows his backstory until one day
when they come for me and i have to hang
up my apron and dust off dust the flower
off my hands and be like i got one more
in me uh yeah i would go into hiding in
a small italian town as a baker that
would that would be my secret identity
the mysterious good one
yeah i i would love to just pick up
baking i feel like during the pandemic a
lot of people learn how to make bread
and i'm so jealous of that so i think
that that's the thing i tried making
bread i got a i got a cabinet full of
yeast now that's no good
i gave it a shot
after 300 calories full of sentience
yeah i'll just buy my bread from the
store thanks so much yes um i think my
secret identity would probably be
something stupid like a smitty wormer
man jansen uh from spongebob um i don't
know if you ever saw that episode where
uh i did not empty
i'm an old man this
like spongebob is
this stupid uh you know those hats were
like you could drink out of like the
sports hats
so like he buys one of those but then
like it's super like important and like
he buries it um in this like person that
he thinks is like mr crabsex is fake
called smitty rubberman jensen and turns
out to be this real guy and um i don't
know i just thought the name was stupid
so i was like i'm gonna be a man named
smitty weber man judson because he was
number one he was number one um sorry
this is all spongebob references
everyone who wants football understand
what i'm saying what would be your your
your job your your your secret job
how you hiding my secret job
i would be
a secret
um
you gotta blend in are you gonna be a
mailman is that he blended yes
like everyone's gonna know who i am and
they'll never suspect that this friendly
mailman is um a secret jedi
that's true so i'll be the friendly
mailman but yes that is it for this
episode of big question thank you to
brandon for joining me on this episode
he's amazing as always please follow him
at grindenberric on twitter you can
follow me on mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
[ __ ] most importantly follow new
rockstars here on youtube and all of our
social media platforms and make sure you
hit that notification bell on youtube so
you can get notifications every time we
upload a video thank you guys so much
for watching we love you times a million
bajillion you guys mean so much to us
have a great week we'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you